critical obviously he pointed out that
there must be safe legal routes put in
place we cannot wait for years for those
to be put in place he said that this
bill is an attempt at a short-term fix
and risks damaging at the UK's
reputation for justice and the rule of
law uh well that's happening on the
right on the left you can see the House
of Commons prime minister's questions is
just getting underway uh let's listen
into that activities in this house I
shall have further such meetings later
today Clive Lewis
speaker two years ago I
run out 18 of his own teeth because he
couldn't get access to a dentist the
Grim fact is despite repeated promises
from the Prime Minister Norwich and
Norfolk remain Dental deserts so Mr
Speaker dentists excel at extracting
rotten teeth so will the Prime Minister
agree with me the only way my
constituents will see results is when
this rotten government is extracted from
office and replaced with a label on
right here
Mr Mr Speaker I'm very sorry to hear
about the honorable gentleman's
constituent with regard to Dentistry
he'll know there are records some is
going into dentistry and indeed 500 more
NHS dentists working today
because of the contract reforms that
we've put in place 10 more activity can
happen and dhse are currently talking
about reforming the dentist contract
with the presidents in practice to
increase activity further
thank you Mr Speaker
my constituent Gordon unfortunately has
been suffering receiving cancer
treatment at the Mount Vernon Hospital
which will soon fall within Sadiq Khan's
new Euless boundaries as Gordon
continues his daily treatment he will
now be expected to pay 12 pound fifty
charge or buy a new compliant vehicle
prime minister agree with me that the
British people already have enough on
without Labor's London mayor stretching
household budget
management
of tfl finances
Mr Speaker I'm sorry to hear a honorable
friends constituent Gordon and I sent
him my best wishes he will know that
transport in London is devolved to the
labor mayor who is expanding The Zone
against the overwhelming views of
residents and businesses and what's more
his plan to raise costs for hard-working
families is totally backed by the leader
of the opposition perhaps he can now
tell us why
I don't think he was responsible for the
question we're now completed the
opposition Can't Stop
can I thank all those who took part in
the coronation celebrations over the
weekend and can I also take this chance
to wish all the very best to my
brilliant and talented constituent May
Muller who is representing the UK
Eurovision in Liverpool this weekend
the whole country is behind you may
now Mr Speaker
this time last week the Prime Minister
had to correct the record of misleading
claims he made about employment numbers
can he provide a further update now he's
cost a thousand Tory councilors their
jobs
[Applause]
speaker
Mr Mr Speaker let me pass on my best
wishes to may as well for this weekend
Eurovision and with regard to the local
elections Mr Speaker maybe I can just
author The Honorable gentleman a tiny
bit of advice from one of his
predecessors
one of his predecessors
one of one of his predecessors Tony
Blair who I was reading the other day
what did Tony Blair he said he said the
right honorable gentleman can be as
cocky as he likes about the local
elections come a general election policy
counts
and we know Mr Speaker
the problem for him is he doesn't have
any
the Prime Minister said he was going to
lose a thousand seats and then he
managed it
13 years a Tory promised they actually
haven't broken
and this is the prime minister who's
only had to fight for two things in his
life last year he lost a Tory beauty
contest to the member for Southwest
Norfolk who then lost to a lettuce
last week when he finally came into
contact with voters he lost everywhere
no matter who the electorate is the
prime minister keeps entering a
two-horse race and somehow finishing
third
given his track record who does he think
he's actually got a mandate from
Mr Speaker it's a bit Rich to hear about
mandates from the person who's broken
every single promise
and go through the list ICA
nationalizations NHS Outsourcing
Universal Credit and now tuition fees he
was Mr Speaker he was for them all
before he was against them he's not he's
not just the softy he's the flaky too
well Mr Speaker I can understand why the
prime minister's trying to wish away his
terrible results but peddling nonsense
just doesn't work up and down the
country people want the government to
focus on the cost of living but he's got
no answers is he planning to carry on as
if nothing happened and ignore the
message he was sent last week or is he
going to do what a labor government
would do and announce an immediate
freeze in council tax bills
[Applause]
Mr Speaker Mr Speaker I know I know he's
asked his labor counselors rightly to
focus on the cost of living perhaps they
could start with reducing council tax to
the level in conservative run areas
but Mr Speaker we're getting on with
holding People's Energy bills freezing
fuel duty to help them with the cost of
living what is stopping him having a
plan is that unfortunately his shadow
Chancellor recently said she's
discovered she's got a problem Mr
Speaker she realized she realized that
she actually is what she said she
actually has to shock horror say where
the money's going to come from
with
a 90 billion pound black hole in her
plans she's got a lot of work to do
there's only one party that broke the
economy and they're sitting right there
and
it seems to me it seems to me to quote
one of his more allegedly successful
predecessors nothing has changed still
blaming other people still refusing to
take the necessary action still not
listening to the country and on council
tax it's quite simple a labor government
would give every Council the grant they
need to freeze those bills fully paid
for by ending the handouts he's giving
to oil and gas giants so I ask him again
now his plan has been utterly rejected
why won't he do the same
Mr Speaker just a quick a quick history
lesson while he was busy while he was
busy softening sentences 13 years ago
let me just remind him what we inherited
it was the largest deficit in the G7
from labor higher unemployment the
coffers were totally empty and it didn't
stop there Mr Speaker after that they
wanted a longer lockdown and now now
they won't even oppose the picketers and
the protesters Mr Speaker
even in opposition they're damaging the
economy
[Applause]
[Music]
even off the entire country Mr Speaker
from the Peak District to the god of
England rejected his government last
week he still thinks that protecting oil
and gas profits is more important than
freezing bills now I
promise the bus finally have met some
many of them understand why he insists
on protecting his precious non-dom tax
status rather than scrapping it and
using the money to train thousands of
doctors and nurses
Mr Speaker he he said that this money
would fund the NHS Workforce but that
plan was actually looked at by one of
his own colleagues recently now now that
person said that it would discourage
doctors and nurses from coming here and
but there was a two billion pound there
was a two billion pound shortfall in his
sons who said that it was Aleister
darling
he might remember those days it's when
labor bankrupted the economy
[Applause]
I think that is the definition of
nonsense this is the price of having a
tired worn out government fronted by a
prime minister who boasts he's never had
a working-class friend he's smiling his
way through the cost of living crisis
gloating about success while waiting
lists grow he's pretending that crime
house building schools are all just
doing fine while handing the country 24
tax Rises all with his name on them
how does he think the tourists can
possibly provide the answers Britain
needs when the whole country has already
told him they're the problem not the
solution
Mr Speaker The Honorable gentleman is
right we all do say some silly things
when we're younger I was a teenager and
he'll he'll know what I'm talking about
because I think in his 40s he was still
talking about abolishing the monarchy Mr
Speaker
all right
[Applause]
minister is it but it's this it's the
it's the same oh God from him every week
Mr Speaker all politics and no action
we're getting on with halving people's
energy bills freezing fuel Duty cutting
the shots of cold care and boosting pay
well he's well he's busy plotting
coalitions we're getting on and
delivering for the British people
Mr Speaker this Saturday is Surrey day a
chance for locals and visitors to
celebrate everything wonderful about our
Kent County including our beautiful
historic High Street in Guildford with
its independent shops but frequently
raised with me is empty shops High rents
with high business rates makes it
difficult for independent retailers to
compete with national chains does my
right honorable friend agree with me
that this government must do everything
it can to support our high streets as
part of our plan to boost economic
growth prime minister let's speak of my
honorable friend is absolutely right
about the importance of high streets for
local communities not just in Surrey but
around the country that's why we are
abolishing business rates for hundreds
of thousands of eligible businesses in
the retail hospitality and Leisure
sector and investing billions of pounds
through the high streets fund and our
towns fund to support local communities
up and down the country SMP spokesperson
Stephen Flynn
thank you Mr Speaker if the Prime
Minister was to go to the boot of his
Land Rover and pull out some placards
which said save our nomdoms would you
expect to be arrested by the police
Mr Speaker Mr Speaker
can I first put on record my thanks to
the police for all their hard work over
the weekend ensuring that the coronation
was a success now look on this issue Mr
Speaker we believe the police should
have powers to make sure that they can
protect the public from unnecessary and
serious disruption I respectfully
recognize that The Honorable gentleman
disagrees with our position I guess the
question for both of us is what does The
Honorable leader of the opposition think
about this because it's quite hard to
keep up
remind the Prime Minister his prime
minister's questions not asking not not
for what the oppositions do is Stephen
Fleet
Mr Mr Speaker what we're talking about
here is the nurses strike doctors strike
firefighters strike Republic protest
firefighters protest and of course of
course Republicans protest as well and
you do so because it's a fundamental
right within our democracy to be able to
protest so as a prime minister seriously
saying that moving forward you can have
your rights but only on his terms
it is also the right of the British
public to be able to go about their
ordinary day-to-day lives without undue
serious disruption that's why it's right
that the police have extra Powers I
suspect that The Honorable gentleman
disagrees with that but we think it is
right and but people will see every day
every day on TV their lives being
disrupted they're not able to get to
school to get to hospital appointments
and indeed to get to work they should be
able to do that and the police should
have powers to stop those who are
preventing that from happening
thank you Mr Speaker it was an honor to
welcome the Australian prime minister to
Barrow last week so we could meet some
of our fantastic apprentices see the
submarine program and reaffirm his
commitment to the orcas program will
deliver thousands of jobs in my
constituency and keep our nation safe
but what was a national Endeavor is now
an international one and it's going to
require a whole of government approach
to get it over the line and deliver it
well so with that in mind could I invite
my writable friend to Barrow to see the
program for himself and also to meet
with me to see how we can best leverage
the opportunities from this for the
people of Barrow for generations to come
well my honorable friend is a fantastic
advocate for his local industry and
community and he's right the SSN orcas
submarines will be built in Barrow the
home of the British submarine industry
it will create thousands of new jobs not
just in Barrow but across the UK that's
why the government is investing billions
to modernize the Enterprise and I look
forward to taking him up on his
invitation and Debbie
bring that strong local champions
they delivered their verdict on the
government's failure to hold water
companies to account for dumping raw
sewage into our rivers and onto our
beaches
last year water bosses were paid 15
million pounds in bonuses rewarded for
destroying our precious natural
environment
three of those Executives have now
turned down their bonuses but they
should never have been entitled to them
in the first place
so will the Prime Minister ban the
sewage bonuses oh boy so that the
dumping actually stops
well prime minister speaker I I
struggled to hear the full the full
question but I think it
in one cent it's one cent in one sense
it doesn't really matter because we all
know the liberal Democrats say one thing
here and another thing locally anyway
no wonder he's attracted to the labor
leader these days Mr Speaker political
opportunism and a broken promise on
tuition fees it must be like looking in
the mirror
[Applause]
Ben Bradley
[Music]
easy to highlight some success with
Mansfield District Council now having
more conservative councilors than at any
point in my lifetime
and I'm very proud of our local
but one thing we heard on the doorstep
was frustration frustrating expectation
the government needs to deliver on key
pledges there has been a commitment to
our part of the world that will be given
the clout the investment to catch up
with other regions that historically
have had more than we've had so all the
prime minister take the opportunity to
reiterate his commitment and to my
constituents reassure them that he will
support growth and investment in the
East Midlands
well Mr Speaker my honorable friend is a
tireless advocate for the East Midlands
and in particular I welcome the
Devolution deal that has been agreed
among the four local authorities in the
region something I know honorable friend
has campaigned for and like him I look
forward to those new devolved
institutions being established as soon
as possible to drive economic growth in
his community Caroline look
thank you Mr
Mrs Leslie declared and I quote my
daughter is the climate change champion
in our house I wonder if he's asked her
what she thinks about rosebank the
biggest undeveloped oil field in the
North Sea which would blow climate
targets create more emissions than 28 of
the world's poorest countries combined
involve the obscene transfer of four
billion pounds of taxpayers money to a
Norwegian energy firm Equinox and do
nothing for energy security since the
vast majority of the oil will be
exported if he gives it the green light
will he be able to look his daughter in
the eye and honestly say that he has
done everything in his power to give her
and all other young people a livable
future
Mr Speaker as the independent committee
for climate change has acknowledged we
will need fossil fuels for the next few
decades as we transition to a Greener
future and during that period it makes
absolutely no sense to not invest in the
resources we have here at home to import
foreign fossil fuels not create jobs
here and import them at twice the carbon
emissions as our local resources it is
an economically illiterate policy Mr
Speaker but that's what you'd expect
from the Green Party
[Applause]
George this thank you Mr Speaker last
June the government uh committed to
bring forward a Horticulture strategy to
identify ways to expand a British
production of horticulture and the
importance of this was underlined by
some of the supply chain challenges we
saw earlier this spring but in the last
week There's Been speculation that the
government might be abandoning that
strategy can the Prime Minister give us
any reassurance that the government
remains committed to expanding this
important British industry prime
minister well can I thank my runnable
friend for all of his work championing
this area we are delivering for the
Horticulture sector and it will benefit
from the 168 million pound investment to
drive Innovation and support through
production and that's why we also passed
the new genetic technology act Mr
Speaker taking advantage of our brexit
opportunities to unlock the potential of
new technologies but I look forward to
discussing this and other ideas at our
new upcoming food Summit
Mr Speaker has the prime minister or any
of his ministers given commitments to BP
Equinox or any other company about
contracts at the teasworks site
Mr Speaker contracts at the site would
be a commercial matter for the companies
involved
[Music]
Mr Speaker our Farmers provide our food
and our countryside's future but there's
concern amongst some Oxfordshire Farmers
that the new schemes under defra's
agricultural transition plan aren't
ready for Farmers to access them to make
up the shortfall from the basic payment
scheme will my right honorable friend
push his colleagues in defra to roll out
the rest of the SFI standards as soon as
possible and to consider double stacking
SFI and Countryside stewardship payments
to ensure that oxyges farmers get the
support they need prime minister Mr
Speaker I thank my honorable friend for
his question and of course we want to
make sure that we continue to support
Farmers to produce healthy nutritious
food we are pressing ahead with the elm
scheme fine-tuning them though to make
sure that they work even better for
Farmers we want to make sure there's
enough flexibility in the sustainable
farming initiatives and that's why defra
have designed the schemes with farmers
in mind enabling them to do more and to
make sure that they can use countries
obscureship schemes on the same plots of
land but I look forward to discussing
this with him and other colleagues as
well Alan Smith
thank you Mr Speaker in Sterling we've
got a really potentially very exciting
development at Fort site on the former
Ministry of Defense land and sadly the
development's got a bit stuck over a
dispute about the cost of the
decontamination of that land no I'll
work with anybody to get a result for
Sterling will the Prime Minister meet
with me in representatives of Sterling
Council to get this development
unblocked and make the progress we all
want to see prime minister well Mr
Speaker we have invested in Sterling
previously to unlock investment and
drive growth and I'll ensure that The
Honorable gentleman gets the meeting he
needs with a relevant minister to make
progress
oh
the Prime Minister and I share a
profound optimism about the power of
technology and AI in particular has the
power to revolutionize public services
and our private sector as well but does
he agree with me that it comes with
risks and while there are uh unrealistic
calls to pause Research into it
altogether it is crucial for us to work
with our allies around the world so that
the global Norms that emerge in this
important area reflect our values yeah
well my uh honorable friend speaks with
experience and knowledge on this issue
and I absolutely agree with the thrust
of his question uh whilst it would be
implausible and wrong to Halt the
development of this technology it is
right that we ensure that there are
appropriate guard rails in place as we
look to exploit those opportunities
those are the conversations we are
having not just with the companies
involved but also with our allies around
the world and he can expect further
progress in the coming weeks and months
thank you Mr Speaker
following on from his earlier answer the
as the Prime Minister knows I need out
to help out scheme was introduced in
August 2020 which increased demand for
eating at restaurants by some 216
compared to 2019 with figures now
showing that over 17 and a half thousand
retail chain stores closed in 2020 award
affecting nearly 35
000 employees would or has the Prime
Minister considered a similar scheme for
bricks and mortar retail bricks versus
clicks if you like as part of the wider
plan for regenerating local high streets
and town centers
well prime minister Mr Speaker the way
that we are supporting High streets and
town centers is through making sure that
we cut business rates in England
obviously the Scottish government will
receive Barnet consequentials from those
actions but now hundreds of thousands of
local businesses on our high streets
don't pay any business rates at all and
on top of that through the leveling up
fund town fund and others were investing
directly in local communities indeed in
his own where I know Council leaders
described our investment of 19 million
pounds as very welcome and a real boost
for the economic recovery now get
through
speaker my rightful friend recently
scored a very rare own goal right back
in stock Stockton football club in the
northern Premier League East playoff
final which eventually saw longington
United win on penalty an interest of
good sportsmanship but they now
congratulate in deakin and his team on
their resounding victory
which belonging to United there was
assessed in the in the league for next
season and joined me at Grange Park to
cheer on longitude United for the next
season which look I've received in the
future
yeah well Mr Speaker can I join
honorable friend in congratulating her
local football team and all involved in
their stunning success I'm not sure if
I'm going to join her in the immediate
future but I do look forward to seeing
them go from strength to strength much
as the fortunes of my own team sadly uh
I'm not in the place I would like them
to be Jamie Stone thank you Mr Speaker
the Prime Minister May well have seen
the astonishing site of a former
Scottish government Minister standing up
in the chamber Scotch bump and tearing
up literally ripping into pieces the
Scottish government's highly protected
Marine area proposal this proposal is
deeply controversial all over Scotland
and has even led to it being compared
with its second Highland clearances is
this not now the time is this not now
the time for the UK government to step
in and work with the devolve
[Applause]
d
speaker I will not be silenced it
matters
[Applause]
this matters deeply to my constituents
is it not time the UK government to step
in work with
the demonstrations to come up with a
scheme that works and is acceptable a
conservation scheme that is acceptable
in our fishing communities all around
the UK
[Applause]
The Honorable The Honorable gentleman
makes an excellent point and he is a
passionate Champion as he should be for
his local fishing communities and he's
right to highlight the concerns that
have been raised not just by them but by
members of the S P's own party about the
potentially damaging impact of their
plans to introduce the highly protected
Marine areas in the way that they are I
would encourage the SMP government to
continue working with the Scottish
fishing industry and Coastal communities
to understand their concerns and as
we've seen them recently you turn on
other poor thought out decisions
hopefully they can re-look at this one
too blue Manchester
United Kingdom has a strong deep
multi-dimensional relationship with
Pakistan and there are over 1.5 million
British pakistanis here and many of them
are dual Nationals as am I the Prime
Minister will have seen the scenes
coming out from Pakistan the civil
unrest where people have lost their
lives due to the Detention of the Prime
Minister Imran Khan there are real
concerns about the circumstances of his
detention and their right to have a fair
trial the United Kingdom has in the past
sent observers to hearings around the
world to ensure natural Justice is done
has the Prime Minister considered that
if not will you consider it prime
minister well Mr Speaker I thank my
honorable friend for his question the UK
of course has a long-standing and close
relationship with Pakistan and this
weekend especially as Commonwealth
Partners the arrest of the former prime
minister is an internal matter for
Pakistan we support peaceful Democratic
processes and adherence to the rule of
law and we are monitoring the situation
carefully
thank you Mr Mr Speaker
because his parents can't afford new
ones a little girl had water on our
cornflakes because her mum had no money
for milk these are real stories from
faith and families a charity in my
constituency that deal with poverty
every day poverty that is causing
prolonged shame and lead into a mental
health crisis faith and families are
worried about these kids I'm worried
about these kids if the prime minister
is worried about these kids what's he
going to do about it
Mr Speaker we don't want any child to
grow up in poverty and that's why I'm
proud that there are 1.7 million fewer
people living in poverty today than in
2010 because of the actions of this and
previous conservative governments that
includes hundreds of thousands of
children and we are providing incredible
support to the most vulnerable in our
society as we speak just last week the
first of our cost of living payments
went out 900 pounds to help the most
vulnerable families in our society those
are our values and we will keep
supporting them as the inflation remains
high
thank you Mr Speaker earlier in
questions the leader of the opposition
sought to draw attention to council tax
rates and council tax increases and
offering some crocodile tears in the
process can I draw attention to the uh
to the prime minister's attention that
whereas we have seen 43 increase in
council tax rates since 2010 in England
the increase in Wales has been a
staggering 67 percent so therefore is it
not the case we should be looking at
what labor do rather what labors say
an excellent point the leader of the
opposition is very fond in telling us
that labor and Wales is his blueprint
for how he would like to run the country
and as we've seen all it means is higher
bills for hard-working British families
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you Mr Speaker over the last two
years the Drax power station in
Yorkshire has on average burned almost
000 tons of trees every single day
releasing an equivalent amount of carbon
into the atmosphere during that time
whilst our constituents have struggled
with their heating bills the private
company running drugs has received one
and a half million pounds of subsidy
through the government's energy policy
every single day this is set to continue
until
2027. can I ask the Prime Minister will
he step in and review this grotesque
Distortion of energy policy which
incentivizes deforestation whilst making
no contribution to tackling the climate
emergency
vehicle will not be able to comment on
the contract details of one particular
company what I can say is that our
record on this issue is that since the
Benchmark was established emissions in
this country have fallen by almost 50
percent whilst at the same time we've
grown the economy by two-thirds not
something I know the s p government is
as focused on as we are but at the same
time because of the way that we regulate
new and renewable energies we've seen
the price of Renewables like offshore
wind declined from 140 pounds an hour to
around 40. that shows a regulatory
system that is working in delivering
lower cost renewable energy for British
families to Costa thank you Mr Speaker
plastic pollution is a scourge of modern
day Society my 10 minute rule Bill seeks
to have
microfiber microplastic filters fitted
in all commercial and domestic washing
machines legislation which France and
other countries have already moved
forward with
will the Prime Minister who has already
done an enormous amount in tackling
plastic pollution will he organize a
meeting between me and the stakeholders
particularly washing machine
manufacturers with the secretary of
state to discuss this very important
issue prime minister Mr Speaker we want
to tackle microplastic pollution
wherever possible which is why we
introduced a microbead ban and a tax on
plastic bags I know my honorable friend
has campaigned for filters on washing
machines but he will also know they can
be costly to install defra have outlined
plans to make sure that we can use more
filters but I will ensure that he gets
the meeting that he needs with the
relevant minister to discuss this
important matter further Stephen Morgan
thank you Mr Speaker the government
ditching its pledge to recruit 6 000
more GPS is yet another example of the
Tories over promising and under
delivering with teacher recruitment
targets missed and housing unpleasures
showed why does the promise to think
that the only target is actually met was
a loss of a thousand Tory councilors
last week
maybe on agenda can tell us which of the
many promises that leader of the
opposition made to him when he was
campaigning he's most happy that he's
you turned on
thank you Mr Speaker on lincolnshire's
roads
food stuff's grown in our fine County
are transported Across the Nation for
the highways Authority struggles to fund
roads because the skewed funding former
formula devised by a previous labor
government so many so many of our
Services suffer policing included so
will the Prime Minister agree to
urgently review The Local Government
funding formula the police timing
formula so that Lincolnshire could have
a fair deal well in my uh my writable
friend is absolutely right to stand up
for the particular needs of his rural
community and like him I recognize that
rural areas do often have high costs of
providing Services it's right that those
are reflected where we can in funding
formulas but I'll make sure that he gets
a meeting with a relevant minister to
discuss this important matter further
thank you Mr Speaker 13 450 people meter
vouchers have gone unclaimed in my
Glasgow Central constituency a value of
over 887
000 pounds across Scotland sixteen and a
half million pounds is unclaimed the
prime minister's Energy bill support
scheme is failing if money which could
be helping a vulnerable constituents is
resting in his government's account I
recall is not very familiar with how
prepayment meters work but what will he
do to ensure that every single penny
gets out of government coffers and into
the meters of those who really need it
Mr Speaker I'm grateful that The
Honorable lady for a change acknowledged
the support that the government is
providing to families up and down the
country particular attention was given
in designing those schemes to how to get
the support to prepayment meters that
ministers are always engaged with
stakeholders to make sure that there is
awareness of those schemes and I'll make
sure that we keep up those efforts so
that people do get the help that they
need and deserve David Morris thank you
very much Mr Speaker Mr Speaker it's
very interesting that the leader of the
opposition says vote keeping council tax
law when the labor party voted to
increase more Compton Town Council from
historically four hundred thousand
pounds two hundred thousand pounds to 2
million so on that basis I'd like to
meet with the prime minister to see
where we can find government time to cap
Parish councils from doing this sort of
the boring Behavior
Mr Speaker honorable friend is right to
highlight that council tax in labor
areas is higher than that in
conservative areas which is not right at
a time when there are pressures on the
cost of living I look forward to meeting
him to discuss his plans to keep British
families household bills as low as they
can be
John speller yeah thank you Mr Speaker
dozens of Sudanese doctors who've been
working in the NHS were stranded and not
allowed to return here last week the
minister told us here that the Prime
Minister took the decision to get them
back so why hadn't such a
straightforward decision was made much
earlier correct by the Home Secretary or
the foreign
because he's an obsessive micromanager
or is it that his ministers are just not
up to the job
Mr Speaker The Honorable gentleman is
completely wrong to describe as
straightforward a complex and dangerous
evacuation in a war zone and actually it
is it is actually the case that everyone
involved deserves enormous credit for
conducting what was the longest and
largest evacuation of any Western
Country from Sudan during that process
it was right that we moved deliberately
and carefully to ensure the security of
everyone involved and to prioritize
British Nationals and their dependents
now that the operation is complete we
can look back and thank everyone for
what was an incredibly successful
operation
those blue cabins
thank you Mr Speaker since 2010
violent crime has dropped by 38 and
neighborhood crime has dropped by over
50 percent but one crime that has gone
up is fraud now many of us have dealt
with constituents who've struggled with
fraud what is the prime minister going
to do about it
my honor friend is absolutely right 40
of all crime now is fraud it's damaging
for people's well-being as well as
harming their finances which is why the
Home Secretary and I just recently
launched a new plan to combat fraud with
significant new investment hundreds of
new officers to tackle it and action on
social media companies to empower people
to take action and to stop fraud
happening in the first place it
represents the most comprehensive plan
to tackle this issue and it will make a
big difference to families everywhere
final question celebration
thank you Mr
space Dean rennell Charles was brutally
murdered on his way out from school in
my constituency in walthamstow yesterday
a 16 year old boy was charged with his
murder
renault's family are heartbroken
children in my community
they said subdue to Cecil rather than
merchandise I probably what I'm saying
is those children are terrified to go to
school their parents are frightened to
let them and their teachers are at their
Wits End they've asked me to come here
today prime minister to beg you to make
the epidemic of Youth crime in our
country a national priority so will the
Prime Minister meet with myself and
representatives from my local community
to talk about how we can get the mental
health and mentoring support these young
people need so that every young person
in our country has that future they
deserve
[Music]
Mr Speaker I hope my uh honorable friend
I know the whole house will join me in
expressing our sympathies and
condolences to renelle's family for
what's happened she's absolutely right
we should do everything we can to tackle
violence and murders against young
people in particular I'm pleased that
knife crime has fallen by almost 10 and
seriously violence has fallen by 24 in
the last few years that's because we are
giving the police the powers they need
whether that stop or shirt search
increasing jail terms and confiscating
around 90 000 weapons of course we will
always look to do more to make sure that
our streets are safe for our young
people that's all for now
well prime minister's questions there
one week after the